all we are doing right now is waking up
to people that we're never gonna vote
for Trump on this one they were ready to
go to DeSantis you just got some of
those guys to say what you know what I
don't think this is fair I'm going back
to Trump I don't think this helps them
every channel every publication every
website he just raised seven million
dollars since being indicted God knows
what that number is going to be by the
end of tonight that could hit a 20 30
million dollar number all by doing this
so Dems may win the battle
but they may lose the war unlike kovit I
think in covet what they did is in covid
Trump won the battle they won the war